hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason TV and
today i'm talking with zack lynch author
of the neuro revolution how brain
science is changing our world zack
thanks for coming and thanks for having
me Nick what the neuro revolution
describe it for us so throughout human
history we've gone through an
agricultural revolution and industrial
revolution and we're in the midst of an
information you've skipped the sexual
revolution well we're that why i have
only has been going on forever but right
so the neuro revolution so the neuro
revolution is where brain science is
literally impacting nearly every aspect
of our lives what are the three kind of
developments in the neuro revolution or
in brain science that excite you the
most well brain science is changing
nearly every aspect of our lives from
marketing to entertainment to law to
theology to art and across there there's
also great implications for medical
sciences talk about say marketing how I
mean we're understanding more about how
the brain works and how it influences
our behavior can seize our behavior you
know how does how does that affect
marketing right so the nascent field of
neuromarketing is very interesting and
it's blossoming there's about 20 firms
worldwide that are focusing on how to
use EEG s and F MRIs new brain scanning
technologies to improve the
effectiveness of advertising does that
create a world of kind of shopping
automatons where we just you know I mean
is this can you press the Bible I mean
is it an update of something like the
hidden persuaders the book about
advertising in the 50s where it said
okay you know what we're going to sell
red cars because red trigger something
in the brain or whatever I mean how does
this move beyond that kind of
sensibility well there are definitely
more advanced techniques and real-time
responses based upon how individuals
their neurobiology actually responds in
which part of the brains actually
respond to particular parts and pieces
of different advertisements does the
individual or something as quaint a
notion of free will or
self-determination over or autonomy does
it go out the window in the neuro
revolution absolutely not no the neuro
revolution is really a broad societal
global revolution where neuro technology
begins to impact nearly every aspect
our lives everything from warfare to how
we develop tools to improve cognitive
fitness so I mean this you talked about
medical advances what are what are the
kind of burgeoning our most exciting
kind of frontiers of medical science as
it relates to neuroscience so there are
two very interesting areas one is
optogenetic neuromodulation this new
technology which has emerged from the
convergence of several technologies over
the past five or six years has given us
the ability to actually tease out and
stimulate specific neural circuits so
rather than a drug which were bathed the
brain in chemicals or conventional
neuromodulation which is like a deep
brain stimulation platform which sends
an electrode to a specific area of the
brain and pulses out electricity opto
genetic neuromodulation actually allows
us to turn on and off circuits within
the brain the technology is very young
but it's very exciting and what we'll
add what will that accomplish well it
might help us understand diseases and
illnesses that are neurocircuitry
specific so it is believed that a lot of
psychiatric illnesses schizophrenia
depression anxiety have less to do with
receptors and more to do with
dysfunctions in overall circuit circuits
and circuitry in the brain so I mean
well neuroscience cure Alzheimer's or
will it make us allow us to understand
it and yes yeah how how will that how
will that make the world better does
this you know does it create a world of
kind of immortal people who never die or
whose bodies dies but their brains live
on forever no absolutely not currently
there are 2 billion people worldwide who
are suffering from some sort of brain
related illness that includes
neurological diseases and psychiatric
illnesses in the United States alone
it's reached over a hundred million
individuals the annual economic burden
of brain related illnesses in the United
States alone has reached over 1.3
trillion dollars a year and that's just
kind of Congress and that's just
counting yet Congress in a couple of
more people run right and so these
technologies
in development will help us sort of bend
the cost curve of future health care
costs what a lot of people worry when as
soon as you start talking about
neuroscience or improving human
cognition and whatnot that you're going
to create two classes a kind of brave
new world of you know the people who
don't have access to this technology and
people who do and pull apart from the
rest of society you know how do you how
do you kind of a switch people's fears
about them well there's fantasy and
there's reality and if you really take a
look at where the technologies are
headed most of the technologies and
development are around enabling people
to perform slightly better at tasks that
individuals around them that are already
performing relatively well there are no
super enhancers out there in development
that are on you know that are coming
down the pipeline lots of people was
like I shouldn't bother taking that si T
again the ambience don't bother so how
do we how do we make neuroscience happen
earlier rather than later in human
history right so over the past decade
I've been involved in several different
initiatives that have been focused on
accelerating the development of
treatments for the brain and nervous
system from everything from launching
conferences to bring together VCS
together with sort of research are
entrepreneurs who are developing these
next-generation treatments launching a
an index with Nasdaq so that you can
track publicly traded neuroscience
companies how can we develop programs to
accelerate the flow of capital towards
these innovative companies with these
new technologies to bring these new
treatments to market room so we need to
harness the free market we need to
harness the capacity of individuals that
are already doing this work and figuring
out how to make it a more attractive
place for private capital to actually
place their money what's the role of
kind of government regulation in either
speeding this up or slowing it down so
another initiative that I've been
working on is the National neuro
technology initiative this is a piece of
legislation that we introduced into
Congress two years ago its focus is on
improving national coordination among
the different agencies that are
focused on neuroscience research and
development the DoD the VA the NIH
there's currently about eight billion
dollars a year spent among those three
different agencies in neuroscience
research and then federal dollars
Federal Circuit right and they're not
coordinating very well correct correct
so what would what would better
coordination me well you could do a
couple of different things you could
have a national coordination office that
would coordinate neuroscience research
occurring among the different agencies
so that they would have their to have
improved visibility and information flow
not necessarily telling them what they
should be doing or how they should be
coordinating but just letting them know
what the different types of research
that's occurring let's say in traumatic
brain injury or post-traumatic stress
disorder in different areas of the
government within the NH itself right
now there are 16 different Institute's
out of the 27 that are currently
unfocused on some sort of brain or
nervous system illness do you think that
I mean is it the market that is going to
deliver the biggest bang for the buck
here in terms of developing and bringing
to market solutions there's a huge
opportunity like I said two billion
people worldwide suffer from a brain or
nervous system so what if if you had one
policy initiative or one policy change
that would allow this to happen more
quickly what would it be I would improve
the ability and capacity for private
companies to be able to invest in
aerotek companies and how would that
happen well we could do it a whole wide
variety of different ways we could do it
through tax policy we could do it
through investment tax credits
specifically focused on neuroscience
related companies I think there's a
broad range of initiatives that we
should be looking at from the
perspective of how we actually instigate
development and investment in this space
if if there's one thing that everyday
people can do to and improve their brain
functioning on a daily basis what is
exercise as i right yeah any kind of
exercise preferably something that gets
your heart rate moving for 15 or 20
minutes why does that help your brain
oxygen gets to your brain and it helps
you
circuitry stay happy I was really hoping
lots of hugs as well lots of hugs
website with oxytocin is better bring
rugs drugs not hugs come on there isn't
a drug that we can take well it depends
on your definition of drugs okay all
right love is the drug right I think
that's a price yeah well I want to thank
Zakk Lynch author of the neuro
revolution how brain science is changing
our world for talking to reason TV today
i'm nick gillespie thanks Zach thanks
Nick